while everyone was focusing on the
latest presidential horse race news over
the weekend steve bannon possibly going
to jail trump possibly declaring his
campaign biden's lackeys fighting over
who takes the reins when the big guy
drops while everyone was focusing on the
big headline news most people missed the
most disturbing
political news story to come up in a
very long time care of cdc director
rachelle wolenski
two little kids just came down with
monkey pox
we do have seen now two cases that have
occurred in children both of those
children are traced back to uh
individuals who come from the men who
have sex with men community the gay ma
mend community um and so when we have
seen those cases in children they have
generally been what i call adjacent to
the community most at risk
i should also mention importantly those
children are doing well
doing well
the children are doing well the children
who for whatever reason are living with
promiscuous homosexual men according to
federal officials just came down with a
dangerous disease a disease that is by
the way especially dangerous for
children it's not super dangerous for
lots of other people
a disease that you pretty much only get
from having sexual contact with gay men
who go to orgies and the kids are doing
well
according to recent research in the new
england journal of medicine 95 of
monkeypox cases have been transmitted
through sexual activity 98 of infected
people are gay or bisexual
41 of them already have aids hiv not
full-blown aids necessarily the median
number of sex partners that the people
who are infected with monkey pox have
had in the prior three months is five
and a third of them are known to visit
orgies and bath houses
within the month of infection
according to our own federal government
ninety-nine percent of american monkey
pucks cases involve men who have sex
with men
some activist groups are trying to blur
this reality and they're claiming that
monkey pox is not a sexually transmitted
disease or they're claiming that it's
affecting all sorts of other people not
just one group in particular the data
just don't back that up not even close
remember when we were supposed to follow
the science until the science was
politically incorrect a sane society
would be demanding answers here
they would be
interrogating the men who gave the kids
this std
the sane society would be demanding the
closures of the gay sex clubs where the
virus spreads we just shut down the
world for two years over a cough a cough
that nothing was able to stop anyway no
matter how hard we tried to shut it down
now we can't shut down a few bath houses
for a little while to stop an entirely
preventable disease that now a couple of
kids have somehow
we can't even ask the obvious questions
that this
bizarre and disturbing story raises
no it's no big deal no big deal the kids
are fine nothing to see here move along
move along i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on friday is from janelle
austring who says as a wise man once
said the kids aren't all right so true
you were saying that with regard to what
we were talking about on friday but
absolutely holds up even truer when we
get to this extremely disturbing story
today when you want to protect yourself
you want to protect your community you
want to protect your home
you know what you got to check out you
got to check out ring right now go to
ring.com
knowles you know about the ring video
doorbell it's incredible technology lets
you see and speak to whoever is at your
door no matter where you are in the
world in the house outside the house
doesn't matter you know about ring alarm
if you don't ring has an award-winning
alarm system it's absolutely fabulous
but do you know about ring alarm pro
this is summer time this is when people
are traveling okay they're away from
home have that peace of mind to know
that your home is protected not just
your physical home which ring alarm
takes care of but ring alarm pro your
digital home too you live so much of
your life in virtual reality make sure
to protect it cnet calls ring alarm pro
a giant leap for home security so be
like me baby go pro have that peace of
mind with a ring alarm pro professional
monitoring subscription you will get the
ultimate in security anything goes wrong
you'll get a call you'll make sure that
you are totally protected have that
peace of mind protect what is yours
protect what matters most to you to
learn more go to ring.com knowles that
is ring.com
knowles
it's not a big deal what's the big deal
move along move along it's okay
everyone's doing fine everything's just
great do you
do things feel just fine and great to
you
when you hear a story like this
kids got this std that you pretty much
only get from gay orgies little kids got
it
and even the cdc is saying they got it
from these gay guys who with without
answering any of the questions what
what's the relationship here what do you
mean household transmission how do they
don't no it's okay never mind don't ask
any questions it's fine
right now this the cdc the public health
authorities are trying to have it both
ways they're trying to scare everybody
about monkey pox and everyone's risk of
getting monkey pox but they can't get
past the
scientific facts which is that
virtually everyone who's getting this is
getting it from promiscuous gay sex so
then when they say well actually even
kids can get monkey pox the obvious next
question is how
how did that happen oh never mind don't
ask that question just be afraid of this
virus the virus that only essentially
only affects this one very niche
community now it's no big deal stop
asking questions especially stop asking
questions about the sexual revolution
this is something we've heard it's not
just homosexuals this is something we've
heard for 60 years now at every single
stage of the sexual revolution going all
the way back to the 60s even going back
further at every single stage people
will say oh what's the big deal
come on what's the big deal stop being
such a prude
you're oh man you're such a square no
it's not what's the big deal about
free love what's the big deal about
promiscuous sex what's the big deal
about the hook-up culture what's the big
deal about
ubiquitous contraception and then
abortion which followed shortly shortly
thereafter what's the big deal with
redefining marriage what's the big deal
with the transgender movement what's the
big deal if a guy wants to pretend to be
a woman what's the big deal with the guy
going into the girls locker room what's
the big deal with the guy taking the
trophies from the women what's the big
deal now with
transing two-year-olds
two-year-olds that's the story
stonewall which is an lgbt group
just posted over the weekend
all this new research and here's what
they said they said research suggests
that children as young as two
recognize their trans identity
yet many nurseries and schools teach a
binary understanding of pre-assigned
gender
lgbtq
inclusive and affirming education
is crucial for the well-being of all
young people
what's the big deal
this this would be
some of the big deal this would be part
of the transiting two-year-olds
is part of the big deal and it's not
just the libs who shrug their shoulders
and pretend oh what's the big deal
it's the squishes it's the squishy
conservatives even more than the
liberals who are the problem here the
liberals know that this stuff is a big
deal that's why they've been fighting so
hard for every aspect of the sexual
revolution took a lot of energy a lot of
resources a lot of time to get us to
this point in society and it was a
political agenda pushed
essentially
all exclusively by the left it was just
abetted and permitted by the squishy
conservatives who said oh it's not a big
deal never mind move along move along
nothing to see here
we all know
we all know
that it is wrong to trans the
two-year-olds we all know that right and
we all know that this research is bogus
but even if it were real even if a
two-year-old
could a two-year-old can barely speak
but if a two-year-old could come up with
some conception of gender identity as
divorced from biological sex and and a
sense of self that recognize that the
little boy is somehow a woman even if
all of that were true we all know it's
wrong and should not be encouraged
and it happened pretty fast didn't it
to go from
1960s free love kind of culture to
what you would call the gay rights
movement that took what about 20 years
or so then to go from the gay rights
movement to redefining marriage that
took about
i don't know 15 years or maybe a little
bit more maybe that was like 20 years
then to go from gay marriage 2015
to
trans and kids that took about i don't
know five years if that and then to go
from trans and kids
including in elementary schools to
transiting the two-year-olds that took
like six months this is accelerating and
every step along the way people say oh
what a big is this a big deal
come on this is a trivial culture war
issue
yeah it's a culture war issue but it
ain't trivial that's why the libs are
spending so much time on it
we all know
if anyone here has ever had a
two-year-old
and you you can picture
these predators these political
predators coming up and trying to trans
your little two-year-old you would
probably feel an instinct to violence
okay you know it's a big deal everybody
knows it's a big deal
where does this come from
where does it come from it comes from
the re the reticence of squishes
to state plain truths because they don't
want to offend people and they don't
want to be politically incorrect you
just saw this with pete buddha judge
pete buddha judge
just
went on tv and lambasted marco rubio
marco rubio refused to vote for a bill
that would redefine marriage that would
enshrine the new obergefell definition
of marriage to say that marriage doesn't
necessarily need to be between a man and
a woman it can be between a man and a
man or a woman and a woman rubio refused
to to vote for that and he said it's
because he doesn't have he doesn't have
time it's a waste of time it's a
distraction buddha judge just called him
out for it republican senator rubio told
my colleague manu raju he's going to
vote no and he called the called the
vote a quote stupid waste of time what's
your reaction on that what's your
message to senate republicans
if he's got time to fight against disney
i don't know why he wouldn't have time
to help safeguard marriages like mine
look this is really really important
to a lot of people
it's certainly important to me i started
my day as i try to do on weekends i try
to give chastain a little bit of a break
and
do breakfast with with both of our our
twins and
that alone that's no small thing as
every parent of small kids knows
it was one of those days where the tray
table wasn't quite
fitting into the high chair and i'm
trying to make sure that they're busy
enough with their little cereal puffs to
give me enough time to
chop up the banana and get the formula
ready and it just
i don't know that half hour my morning
had me thinking about how much i depend
on and count on my spouse
every day and our marriage deserves to
be treated equally
there is so much wrong with what buddha
judge just said but my first reaction
listening to that clip my first reaction
is man
that guy's got a point
now
when you want to be really precise about
all sorts of details when you really
want to get to the point you got to
check out ramp right now go to
ramp.com do you want a better way to
simplify your business finances across
expenses payments and accounting if so
ramp could be a complete game changer
ramp is a corporate card and financial
software suite designed to help you save
time and put money back in your pocket
ramp gives finance teams unprecedented
control and insight into company spend
with ramp you are able to create budgets
issue cards to every employee with
limits and restrictions and automate
expense reporting so you can stop
wasting time at the end of every month
businesses that use ramp they save an
average of 3.3 percent the first year
ramp is easy to use get started issue
virtual and physical cards and start
making payments in less than 15 minutes
whether you've got five employees or 5
000 employees now get 250 dollars when
you join ramp go to ramp.com knowles
that's ramp.com knowles r-a-m-p dot com
slash knowles credit cards issued by
celtic bank members fdic
rubio comes out and he says i'm not
going to vote for the gay marriage bill
because it's a waste of time it's a
distraction sure it is a waste of time
because there's no threat to obergefell
the supreme court has said explicitly
they're not going to overrule it
certainly not any time in the
foreseeable future it is a democrat
issue to try to save themselves from all
the issues they're failing on this year
on the economy and foreign policy on
immigration they're failing on
everything and so they're trying to gin
up a non-issue at the moment to give
them some umph in november that's all
true but buddha judge has a point too
when buddha judge says what you're
telling me it's a you don't have time to
do this what are you talking about
you're a you're a politician you guys
waste time in all sorts of different
ways
this isn't about time marco rubio this
isn't about time at all you could find
time if you wanted to to safeguard my
marriage and on that point buddha judge
is absolutely right this is not about
time
what i suspect i don't know i don't talk
to marco rubio what i suspect it is is
that marco rubio doesn't think that gay
marriage is real i think marco rubio
believes that marriage he believes as
virtually every single person has for
all of human history everywhere in the
world that marriage is between a man and
a woman and that there is no such thing
as same-sex marriage and that p buddha
judge though he keeps calling his
relationship with this guy jason a
marriage it's not really a marriage he
has a long-term relationship
he has
gone through a technological and
financial process to purchase the eggs
of an of a woman and then to create a
child in a in a test tube
with the intention to it to deprive that
child of his natural mother so that he
and jason can feel more like they're in
a real marriage a real marriage which
has the possibility of generating
children but
i suspect what rubio thinks is that none
of that is real and that actually
marriage does have a meaning and it's
the same meeting it's always had
and we can't just radically change it
but rubio doesn't want to say that
and conservatives generally don't want
to say that
because it's very politically incorrect
it's an extremely difficult issue the
libs are pretty much on board with gay
marriage and half the the republicans
are too and so as a tactical matter what
rubio is trying to do is say oh it's a
waste of time i don't want to i don't
want to answer on the substance of
marriage so i'm just going to make a
kind of procedural point and move along
and buddha judge is calling him out for
it saying whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
mister
well what about my marriage what about
and then he goes through this whole
political routine of i wake up in the
morning and i'm the one who prepares the
formula for my children why is he
preparing formula because neither he nor
his husband can breastfeed because
they've deprived these children of a
natural mother intentionally and
conservatives i think know that's wrong
at a deep level but buddha judge is
daring rubio he's saying i dare you to
tell me that's wrong
you won't do it you won't do it you
coward
so now you're gonna make up some lame
excuse and in defense of rubio i
i don't think rubio is necessarily
inexcusable here in in his
in his tactic i think this is probably
the best political tactic that rubio can
use at the moment and in the short run
it might get him past this vote might
get them past the midterms maybe it's
the smart play to make in the short run
in the long term though that's never
going to work in the long term all that
is that we don't have time this is a
distraction all that is is it is a
surrender on the issue of marriage
buddha judge makes this point beyond
rubio he says it's amazing
i go and i talk to these republicans and
we have a nice conversation and then
they go ahead and vote against my
marriage
i don't understand
how such a majority of house republicans
voted no
on our marriage on as recently as
tuesday hours after i was in a room with
a lot of them talking about
transportation policy having what i
thought were perfectly normal
conversations with with many of them on
that subject only for them to go around
the corner and say that that my marriage
doesn't deserve to continue
he doesn't pete doesn't understand that
so let me explain it because i
understand how this could be confusing
here's how you explain that
most republicans most conservatives are
nice people
generally speaking they're nice people
who wish only the best for pete bootage
and chase him
and
everybody with all sorts of
eccentric sexual views and desires and
identities and everything they really
wish the best for everybody and
the the republicans and the
conservatives they want to work with
everybody in good faith
but
they still believe that marriage has
the meaning that marriage has always had
and there's no degree of
nice conversation with pete but a judge
there's no degree of pete but a judge's
earnest wish that reality were different
than it is that can change that fact
the the problem here is not that
conservatives and republicans hate pete
but a judge well i don't like pete buda
judge generally he's my least favorite
democrat but it actually does not have
to do with his sexual desires it has to
do with his extreme glibness and his
extremely shallow politics and that just
kind of you know hey come on guys let's
just totally redefine society
come on and the fact that he looks like
alfred newman all of that bothers me but
the sex stuff is really secondary to all
of that
the
when it comes to pete buddha judge's
sexual desires
it's not that conservatives hate pete
bootage hate homosexuals have some
irrational animus toward homosexuals
it's just that
pete budage isn't really married
and it's it's hard i know it's hard to
say that in our politically correct
culture but
it's not because you can't two guys
can't be married to each other
marriage is
the
union
of
a man to his wife
a perpetual union of a man to his wife
for the sake of the generation and
education of children that's what it is
and that's not possible between two men
and two women marriage essentially has
sexual difference at the heart of it
and so if we
call things that don't have that
marriage
we don't expand marriage we just get rid
of marriage
if pete buddha judge and jason can be
married then marriage has
no concrete meaning
what what is marriage then you know
walsh asked that question what is a
woman what is marriage
well it's a union
of
two people who love each other
i don't know some marriages the couple
they don't love each other
they stay together and they remain in
that institution they don't necessarily
love each other so okay it's a union of
two people
of no particular sex who may or may not
love each other well at least they
you know they do that thing that married
couples do at least they have sex right
well i don't know they're married
couples who don't really have sex so
okay they may they may or may not love
each other and they may or may not have
sex and they uh well it's a perpetual
union right they can't split up it's
it's a union what god has joined no man
can can rip us under right no except
couples get divorced all the time now so
they
they may or may not stay together and
well they have children right well no
it's impossible for homosexuals to have
children but they can purchase eggs from
women and purchase rent other women's
wombs through surrogacy and then
intentionally deprive those children of
their natural mother and then raise them
you know as though they were in a
marriage and so i guess that's possible
they don't need to do that either you
don't
even in
in marriage today there's no uh
social demand that people have children
lots of people get married and don't
have children so then what the hell does
marriage mean
a union of people who may or may not
love each other who may or may not have
sex who may or may not stick together
who may or may not have children so it's
just
just two people who have some relation
to one another it just doesn't
it just
can't mean anything then
it just means nothing and that's the
problem and that's the conservative
objection
cons trust me man conservatives really
really wish that we could convince
ourselves that pete but a judge and
jason are married it would make politics
a lot easier
it would make life a lot easier it would
feel a lot better that we don't have to
say hard truths saying hard truths is
difficult sometimes
but it you can't convince yourself of
that because it's just
so obviously
not true
i hope that explains it pete i'm not i'm
not sure that it does speaking i i i
think it explains it but i'm not sure
that pete's willing to hear that
speaking of transportation speaking of
transportation the mayor of new york is
very very upset mayor of new york city
is big lib he supports illegal
immigration new york's big sanctuary
city they're all fine with that
but now the mayor of new york is very
very upset because the texas governor
greg abbott is shipping all the illegal
aliens that the libs in new york and
elsewhere are encouraging to flood
across the border
they're shipping them up to new york
city and the new yorkers don't like that
this is a real burden on new yorkers as
we're trying to do the right thing
of we already as i stated we already
have an overburdened shelter system so
now we're talking about as you stated
food clothing school
this is going to impact our
of our schools because we do not turn
away individuals because they're
undocumented translation services
there's just a whole host of things that
this is going to produce and that's why
we need we need help and getting is done
and we need the right coordination to
make it happen
that's that's what we need to do it's
creating a huge burden it's just a big
burden and it's unfair to ask new
yorkers to bear that burden
oh hold on
i thought i thought migration was our
strength
i thought all this diversity was our
strength and it's really really great it
makes america so much stronger so how
come you don't want it in your backyard
mayor adams how come you don't want it
new yorkers
it's a what it's a strength for texas
and arizona and it's the strength for
all those red states where they're going
to see the the electoral demographics
changing but it's not a strength for new
york what do you mean it's putting a
burden on the system but no i i was told
that the migrants who are coming over
don't need any additional resources they
aren't putting any burden on the on the
criminal justice system or on the
welfare system no they're not there
they're a net positive in every way for
society no you're telling me there are
costs to this you just want to impose
those costs on the red states and on the
other people down south and texas and
everywhere else
you support illegal mass migration as
long as it's not in your backyard okay
now it starts now it's starting to make
sense to me
when you want to have a real community a
stable community
in social media in the virtual space you
got to check out tuvu right now go to
tuvu.com we are facing a mental health
crisis that is directly linked to big
tech social media platforms
these platforms are designed to addict
you to likes the affirmation of others
not very healthy they're funded by
advertising that for the first time in
history is tailored specifically
individually for you
the goal is to cater to your every whim
whether those whims are edifying or
destructive very often they're
destructive and they're reinforced by
social media thankfully there's a new
social media app that breaks the mold of
the advertising based model designed
with your best interests in mind it's
based on connection not addiction that's
tuvu tuvu is the social app where you
can share what matters to you by
offering a membership-based platform
built on family values and freedom toovu
makes it possible for you to have a
guilt-free social media experience on
tuvu you won't see a single ad as you
look through posts your data will never
be sold to advertisers and data miners
for profit it's part of changing social
media for the good you can follow me at
michael j knowles when you download tv
you try it free for seven days then it's
just 299 a month you won't miss it go to
tuvu
tuvu.com
knowles okay i know the other social
media apps seem free when they're free
you're the product okay head on over to
tuvu you can download the tuvu app on
google play or the app store and
remember to follow me
i want to talk to you about daily wire
plus right now daily wire plus is our
growing place for movies documentaries
and content that you will not see
anywhere else including very soon kids
content what daily wire plus ultimately
will be is an independent multimedia
empire beholden to
no one this means we are not subjected
to shareholder rules or coerced by pc
culture to go against our core beliefs
this is really really important and
pretty much no one else has ever done
this and it's great the content you see
on daily wire plus is untarnished by the
woke establishment to support us head on
over to
dailywireplus.com become a member today
and get 35 off your new membership
that's dailywireplus.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
speaking of illegal immigration
bill barr former attorney general of the
united states
just made a really important and
interesting point about immigration
that i think should be able to unite
pretty much all of the conservatives
take a listen
i think mexico is well on its way to
being a failed narco state
i don't think amlo has either the the
disposition or the ability to take on
the cartels
uh i think they've they're dragging
their feet
uh i think he was hoping for a modus
vivendi
where he sort of leave the cartels alone
as long as deaths they wouldn't you know
kill as many mexicans that hasn't worked
out for them
so the united states is relegated to
working through mexico to try to deal
with the cartels and i think that's a
losing proposition because i don't think
the mexicans at least with this
administration
are serious enough i think they have to
be forced and pushed into action with us
i think we have to be more active
against the cartels in my mind we have
to approach the cartels more like isis
and less like the mafia
and the idea of a case-by-case
prosecution down there to stop these
organizations would be like going after
you know isis and syria on the same
basis
they are effectively terrorist
organizations they are increasingly
building their connections with
terrorists
if they have uh they are paramilitary
their paramilitary can take on the
mexican military and they have so much
money they can corrupt any system
and we are doing basically nothing about
it
the state department and the pentagon
should be viewing these cartels in
mexico as priority number one the reason
i say that bill barr's comments i think
should unite a lot of conservatives here
is that there are a lot of divisions on
the conservative side some conservatives
want to go in and go bomb a bunch of
countries and some conservatives are
very isolationist and they pretty much
never want to leave american shores some
conservatives are really tough on the
drug war some of the more libertarian
people in the conservative camp they
don't really care about drugs
but everyone here i think should be able
to agree
that
mexican cartels that essentially control
the nation directly south of our border
that are pouring poison across our
border illegally in contravention of our
laws and contravention
of the desire of the american people
killing actual americans in huge numbers
because of this drug problem you're
seeing for the first time in
ever and you've seen it now for several
years the average life expectancy in the
u.s starting to decline everyone should
be able to agree this is a big problem
this should be priority number one for
the state department and the pentagon i
think even even the isolationists should
be able to agree with this certainly the
people who want a more robust foreign
policy you say look
look pentagon
look state department you want to go
deal with problems in the middle east
you think that america has a real
strategic interest in keeping boots on
the ground in the middle east because of
the growth of terrorist groups or
because of oil interests or whatever
okay
okay hey pentagon state department you
think that america has a real strategic
interest in fighting a war with russia a
proxy war with russia in ukraine which
is what's going on right now i know it's
not a declared war but we are at war
with russia in ukraine we are funding
the ukrainian side we've had americans
die in ukraine okay but let's say you
think that's really really important for
america's strategic interest okay
fine you're going to do that you can
keep on doing that
but first you've got to take care of the
cartels on the border whatever you think
about the middle east whatever you think
about ukraine
i think it is
undeniable
that the drug cartels
at right at home right on our doorstep
pose a much greater threat to american
national security they are the cartels
are the ones who control the borders so
you have two million illegals pouring
across the border every year national
security threat major economic problem
actual threat to democracy because it
changes the voting base of the country
that's a much bigger problem you want to
talk about threats to the public health
you want to talk about threats to
american lives the fentanyl pouring
across the border because of the drug
cartels are a much greater threat so
okay you want to go bomb the middle east
fine you want to go bomb the russians in
ukraine fine bomb the freaking mexican
drug cartels first
go in there
flex a little bit of muscle i am pretty
cautious about how we use the american
military
i don't think that guys in uniforms are
just expendable because they happen to
sign up and wear a uniform they're there
to protect american interests and
american lives
those two things the american nation
american sovereignty and certainly
american lives those are facing a far
greater threat from mexico go in there
decapitate the cartels
go go
down and just rip them to shreds salt
the earth where the cartels once
operated and come back done and then the
state department and dod wants to go
play around in the middle east or in
eastern europe or wherever okay fine
that's a secondary issue take care of
the actual problem first the american
military exists for this problem
okay if
if
the drug cartels in mexico if the failed
narco state right on our border that is
flooding our country with poison and
foreign nationals if that is not a
legitimate use of the american military
to stop that then there is no legitimate
use of the american military and bill
barr bill bar is an interesting figure
to raise this suggestion because he's
got establishment cred he's got
trump cred he was a strong defender of
trump and then at the end he turned a
little bit on trump but not entirely but
so he's got still got a little bit of
trump cred and he's still got
establishment credit going back a long
time people everyone's got all these
kind of mixed feelings about him
this suggestion really really good one
speaking of america's role in the world
and foreign interests former cia
director james woolsey just made some
headlines because he went on cable news
and he was asked whether or not the
united states meddles in other countries
elections
and he didn't want to lie
have we ever tried to meddle in other
countries elections
oh probably but uh it was for the good
of the system in order to avoid the
communists from taking over for example
in europe
uh in 47 48 49 the greeks and the
italians we don't do that now though we
don't mess around in other people's
elections
only for a very good deal
do a vine video on those former cia
directors only for a very good cause of
the interests of democracy thanks for
being here well only for a very good
cause and then laura lets him off the
hook so he's saying yeah yeah we
interfere in other countries elections
this reminds me of of something that
john bolton the former national security
adviser got in trouble for a little
while ago he was he was being
interviewed by jake tapper and tapper
was trying to get him to say january 6th
was a coup
and john bolton laughed at him and said
he's not a coup
look i mean i don't like january 6 but
it's not a coup look as someone who's
been involved in planning coups around
the world that wasn't a coup okay and
they were shocked and bolton came out
and he said of course the united states
helps to plan coups of course we have
foreign interests stop being such
snowflakes that's what we do we pursue
this around the world and that's just a
fact
okay that's just a fact you might say
well i wish that we weren't doing that
i wish i wish that the united states
could just mind its own business and not
have anything to do with world affairs
and and maybe that's there's a kind of
admirable or noble aspect to that wish
but it's it's just a pipe dream
powerful countries have interests
powerful countries pursue those
interests around the world that has
always been the case that will always be
the case and no amount of wishful
thinking is going to change that it's
kind of the theme of today's show
i know you've got wishful thinking but
reality is reality okay and that's true
on domestic issues social issues it's
true around the world
so if you if you want to change some
aspect about how things are going
you've got to deal with reality you've
got to get past this question of should
america intervene in other places around
the world
and you've got to ask what i think is a
much more relevant question which is how
should we intervene we are going to
intervene all powerful nations always
protect their interests around the world
that always happens there's no way
around it
marriage has a meaning marriage has
always had a meaning marriage we'll
always have that meaning
it's there are
we have interests around the world okay
how should we pursue those interests
where should we intervene
what
should america this is a big divide
among republicans and democrats should
we be a little closer to saudi arabia
and oppose iran or should we be a little
closer to iran and oppose saudi arabia
it's not easy to answer that question on
the back of a napkin with a few
ideological bullet points but those are
the real questions that are going to
affect the rest of the world do we
interfere in other countries elections
you damn right we do and we do it in
such a way that will
we hope benefit the united states and i
don't see anything particularly wrong
with that if we don't violate justice
now speaking of dubious elections
speaking of elections that have raised
some questions joe biden joe biden you
know the most popular president ever
he got i think a hundred bazillion votes
he's everyone just loves that don't
forget about the opinion polls forget
about the the
dismal approval ratings he's got he's
the most popular guy ever
and uh there's really great news coming
out of the white house the white house
kovid chief ashish ja
wanted to update us on biden's covet
condition and he told us that joe biden
finished his breakfast like a big big
boy
he slept well last night
he ate his breakfast and lunch
i
fully
he actually showed me his plate
didn't ask about the menu but i did see
an empty plate with crumbs and
that's good that's good news that joe
biden's a big big boy and he finished
his breakfast and his lunch and now if
he if he remains a good little boy he
might get some dessert maybe they'll
give joe one of those ice cream cones
that he loves so much hahaha and there's
the press laughing
this kovid chief
is making a joke about how joe biden is
senile that's what the joke is and
that's what the white house is laughing
at
the joke is joe biden is such a
simpleton
in his dotage
that he is
he can when he finishes his plate for
breakfast and lunch that's a really big
accomplishment show me show me the clean
plate here you go can i have a lollipop
yes hahaha
and then the the press laughs because
everyone knows that joe biden is seni
island it's just
taken as a fact
no wonder the country is falling to pot
so what what is the biden administration
going to do
to turn around the country that is
collapsing in
some part because joe biden is senile
and missing in action
let's just look at the economy the
economy is in shambles it is collapsing
everything is much more expensive than
it was a year ago it's over nine percent
more expensive than it was a year ago
people are having trouble heating their
homes well they don't have to heat them
right now because we have a heat wave
going on but they're having trouble air
conditioning their homes they're having
trouble filling up their gas tanks
they're having trouble buying groceries
so what is the white house going to do
about this obvious recession that we're
heading into well the white house is
going to
change the definition of recession
that's what they're going to do this is
what they do you know i hate to say i
told you so i wrote a whole book about
this
now the lives the primary instrument
that they use for changing the political
order is changing all the language
that's why the word marriage matters
they didn't win any debate over what
marriages they just changed the
definition of marriage that's why the
transgender debate matters they didn't
win any debates over transgenderism they
just changed the definition of man and
the definition of woman now if you
google it the definitions are actually
different because the libs just try to
change reality by
artificially altering the meanings of
the words and now they're doing it with
recession
this from jackie heinrich
bracing for impact
even if thursday's gdp report shows a
second consecutive quarter of negative
growth
you won't hear at the biden
administration using the r word here's
what here's what the white house is
saying i got it right off the white
house website
well some maintain
what is a recession well some maintain
that two consecutive quarters of falling
real gdp constitutes a recession
that is neither the official definition
nor the way economists evaluate the
state of the business cycle
put a pause there hold on
it's clearly the way
that
some economists
evaluate the state of the business cycle
that's clearly i don't know if there is
an official definition but that
definition that they just gave that is
the definition i've heard from my entire
life about what a recession is
two consecutive quarters of falling real
gdp
is a recession
but they say no that's not who says who
says
and then the white house concludes it is
unlikely that the decline in gdp in the
first quarter of this year even if
followed by another gdp decline in the
second quarter
indicates a recession
but it
it does by definition
that's what a recession is this is this
is exactly the same argument as when
they say just because
a person has two x chromosomes and
breasts and uh womb uh uterus you know
and ovaries that doesn't mean that that
person is a woman
no it does it that's exactly what that
means no but what if it didn't
what if upward down
what if black were white
what if
my aunt had testicles well then she
would be my uncle that's what would
happen they just try to change
all of the words so that is a sign of
real desperation here because they can't
do anything about the economy biden has
tried every trick he's released an
irresponsibly large amount of oil out of
the strategic petroleum reserve to try
to artificially keep gas prices a little
bit lower than their record highs up
until the midterms that strategy ends
just before the midterm so it was just a
political strategy to stop the bleeding
for the democrats he's trying that
he's begging saudi arabia to release
more money he's trying everything that
he can do other than ramp up american
energy which would irritate his base
they're so desperate
that now the best thing they can do
is just try to change the words
so trying to change the words they're
trying to deny reality they're also now
attempting to jail their political
opponents
steve bannon
the ceo of the trump campaign 2016 a top
adviser to trump in the white house
he was then kind of booted out of the
white house by trump and trump did it in
one of those spectacularly trumpian ways
where he referred to him as sloppy steve
and got into a big fight with him in
public steve bannon though remained
loyal and has remained a trump supporter
steve bannon
may very likely be going to jail now
a dc jury has convicted steve bannon of
two counts of contempt of congress
congress subpoenas steve bannon steve
panning resists and he cites executive
privilege and he cites all sorts of
things and so they prosecute him this is
not often that people will be prosecuted
for this sort of thing and the dc jury
convicted him which means that bannon
now faces between 30 days to a year in
prison for each of the charges
i want to thank the jury for what the
effort they did the judge particularly
the court administration here everybody
i only have one disappointment and that
is the gutless members of that show
trial committee the j6 committee didn't
have the guts to come down here and
testify in open court thank you very
much
so steve bannon triumphant even as he is
convicted and very possibly going to be
sentenced to jail time
and it it showed one of the real real
miscalculations here from the libs
which is that
this conviction for steve bannon that
they're all gloating over and they're
saying ha ha take that steve c in an
orange jumpsuit this conviction for
steve bannon is the best thing to happen
to him since he was in the white house
maybe steve bannon goes to jail maybe
maybe he goes to jail for 30 days or 60
days
so what
steve bannon has not been this
politically relevant since he was in the
white house
and he left the white house sort of in
disgrace trump was really mean to him on
his way out of the white house and
bannon remained loyal and kept plugging
away
and now
he's elevated to this this very high
position
he is going to go down he's going to go
to the trenches he's going to be in the
in jail
for donald trump so i'm not surprised
that steve bannon is gleeful there in
that press conference he's probably
hoping that he gets at least a week or
two in jail
just to build up that credibility and
what does this say for trump trump
should be thrilled about this too
what this says for trump is
trump is is the main threat in the eyes
of democrats
desantis as well i'm not saying desantis
is not a threat i think the democrats
are terrified of him some other
republicans as well they're probably
afraid of they're always attacking ted
cruz i think that is a sign that they do
fear ted cruz to some degree some other
josh hawley a little bit too
but trump is the big one that they're
going after that's why they're trying to
jail his campaign staff
okay that's why they're trying to
take him to court that's why they're
trying to investigate him that's rather
why they're trying to bar him from
running for re-election
if i were trump i would be very happy
with this news because i'd say oh i'm
the number one target okay that means
i'm the one that they fear and trump is
going to sell that message
now i actually just heard from a friend
of mine who lives in austria right now i
heard from him yesterday who said that
the the austrian the viennese newspaper
ran a huge hit piece on ron desantis and
he said this is really unusual
you you don't see this kind of thing in
europe
this early before a presidential primary
that even the europeans who are all big
libs they are afraid of ron desantis as
well so desantis can make that argument
say no they're really afraid of me but
right now right now trump is the main
opposition there is no question about
that and they're they're now making it
harder to try to challenge elections
that that comes from the electoral vote
count the electoral count act update
uh this was a story last week it didn't
get very much attention at all but there
is an act being put up before the
congress the electoral count reform and
presidential transition improvement act
it's co-sponsored by all the moderates
okay it's it's co-sponsored by susan
collins joe manchin portman cinema
romney shaheen murkowski warner tillis
murphy cupido carden young coons sass
and lindsey graham
and the bill got it here the electoral
reform count act the bill is to make it
harder to challenge dubious elections so
they've got some things in here that
they they want a single conclusive state
slate of electors so there's no question
of who the electors are after the
election they want it to be clear that
the vice president has no role in the
count that was a big topic of
controversy in 2020 does the vice
president have any role in accepting or
rejecting the slates of electors they
say the vice president has no role it's
just a ceremonial position they want a
higher objection threshold so the
threshold to lodge an objection to the
electors has to be at least one-fifth of
the duly chosen members of the house of
representatives and the senate which
would raise the threshold right now it's
just a single member of both chambers is
all that's needed that's when ted cruz
and paul gosar stood up and challenged
the count and they want to protect the
state's popular vote
so this is a bad idea
it's a bad idea because the the point of
this law and the effect of this law will
just be to make it harder to challenge
dubious elections
the problem is the elections are
becoming more dubious the elections are
becoming susceptible to fraud in 2020
whatever you think about joe biden or
donald trump or who won the election it
is undeniable that they changed
so many of the rules right before the
election in ways that made the election
much more vulnerable to fraud even by
the standard of barack obama even by the
standard of the democrats by extending
election day to election week or
election months
by
pushing widespread in many cases
unsolicited mail-in ballots in
contravention of the state constitution
of pennsylvania for instance by
all of these by taking forever to count
the ballots
by
uh stopping the ballot counts in the
middle of the night for some reason
but on and on and on you see elections
that are more dubious that are more
vulnerable to fraud and at the very same
time the squishes are pushing to make it
more difficult to challenge those
elections that is a grave threat to our
democracy that's a great threat to all
these sorts of things and then we'll get
to this a little bit more tomorrow
but it's worth mentioning today because
it ties in the dems are really afraid of
trump's radical plan for his second term
the radical plan for trump's second term
that's being touted in axios by jonathan
swann is that trump plans to fire a lot
of the deep state and replace them with
his guys
and and the piece notes that ordinarily
when a presidential administration comes
in they can swap out about 4 000 people
the federal bureaucracy is about 2
million people it's humongous and so
they usually swap out about 4 000 maybe
and trump plans to swap out about 50 000
and this is a huge threat to our
democracy to get rid of the career
leftist bureaucrats almost exclusively
leftist bureaucrats who exert a huge
amount of control over our government
and who usually implement and even make
most of the real laws that govern us
they say that the huge threat for
trump's second term is he might actually
be able to get something done
oh no we can't let that happen if we
allow the people to elect someone who's
then allowed to govern that would be a
grave threat to our democracy
that's that's what we hear from our
extremely
corrupt government you can tell
something has changed in the country
things have decayed things are getting a
little bit worse we have fewer political
rights we we're sicker the economy is
collapsing we've got debauchery and
degeneracy galore we've got kids who
have freaking monkey pox and we're not
even really allowed to ask questions
about that something has gone wrong if
you don't like the trajectory that we
are on you need to get very very serious
about the political process and have the
hutzpah to stand up and say no we're not
just going to keep going along with
these things we're not going to be the
democrats from five years ago and just
go along the same path to quote-unquote
progress albeit a little bit more slowly
we're going to offer an alternative and
we're going to have the courage to
pursue it i'm michael knowles this is
the michael nola show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
hey there this is john bickley daily
wire editor in chief and co-host of
morningwire on today's episode the most
important week of the summer begins with
crucial economic information to be
released
controversy swirls around the house
contraception bill and the attacker of a
republican new york gubernatorial
candidate is released within hours due
to bail reform laws
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire